[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i don't want to keep albert breer
waiting kind enough to join us on short
notice senior nfl reporter lead content
strategist from the monday morning
quarterback and uh i think you're gonna
get a blizzard up uh your way there
albert
yeah i had a uh well that's gonna hit
you guys too i would think right i think
i think you get a big uh bigger one up
there yeah i had a uh i so i actually
planned to head for it i booked my
flight to kansas city at 5 00 a.m on on
saturday morning to try to beat it and
then last night i got one of those
notifications on your phone from like
american airlines saying it had already
been canceled oh so like 36 hours ahead
of time i spent like two hours on the
phone trying to work everything out so
i'm flying out at i think 5 pm today so
hopefully i'll make it out okay today
but yeah i mean apparently we're getting
two feet or something like that i don't
know we'll see
what's the atmosphere in kansas city
like and how is that comparable to any
other place or is it
i'd say it's like a college atmosphere
you know um there are a few of them that
are like that like where the fans are
right on top of you and it is
i mean like very very loud like i think
buffalo and green bay both feel like
college stadiums too just because of the
way the the stands are situated and
they're much closer to the players you
know
um and so like i think the combination
of noise which
like some other stadiums do have noise
um the combination of noise and like
just them the stadium being like
physically smaller and less spread out
than the new stadiums i think makes it
like kind of intimidating for for
opponents and so
um yeah i can't wait to get out there
and it's going to be interesting too you
know to see
cincinnati and joe burrow and jamar
chase all these guys who sort of changed
the face of who the bengals are get to
operate in that sort of environment
um what happened yesterday given
my interview with sean payton the
cowboys said mike mccarthy is coming
back why why yesterday like i don't i'm
i'm trying to follow all of this
of why did it take this long
for what we thought was
just rubber stamping mike mccarthy was
coming back but it felt like there was a
little bit of gray area here was there
yeah dan quinn's the domino yeah i mean
i think i i i think jerry jones and
steven jones fell in love with dan quinn
over the last year
and
i think part of the uncertainty was not
wanting to lose
and looking at the potential for having
to go
into 2022
with a new defensive coordinator maybe
even a new offensive coordinator kellen
moore still in play in miami
like and
so what does that look like and so
you know i i don't think that they were
walking mike mccarthy out in the plank
but i do think to some degree there was
like let's play this let's let this play
out a little bit especially when you see
dan quinn is interviewing in all of
these different places you know and then
you know dan doesn't get the the denver
job
and like he sort of comes to this
realization i really love my job right
now why i want to get that
i think it was a combination of things
timing's part of it um nathaniel hackett
did a great job in his interview i think
there's the bonus that nathaniel hackett
brings with him which is the
relationship with aaron rodgers
um and i i just think that like over the
last couple of days
george payton's got a very close
relationship with dan quinn and if this
you know if you go back like a couple
weeks
i i think george payton if he you gave
him truth serum he'd tell you quinn was
like 100 the leader going into the
process
i think nathaniel hackett did enough to
win over george payton but also did
enough to win over other people in that
building and he's such a positive
presence and then you've got the
relationship with rogers you've got the
work that he's done with different
quarterbacks like he had to work with
e.j manuel and buffalo he had to work
with blake bortles in jacksonville
so like the combination of like
intelligence and energy and you know
sometimes too dan teams go the other way
right like so they had the older more
experienced guy right like before and
vic fangio now you see the younger more
energetic guy so i think it was a
combination of things
and then i think you know for for dan he
made he's maintained this for months you
know like i am not just going to job
jump i'm not i'm not going to just take
the second opportunity because it's
sitting there in front of me
i think after it was a no from denver he
gets back from chicago
um you know on wednesday night wakes up
thursday morning and it's a little bit
like what am i doing
i love my job here i'm not 100 sold on
these other places if it was denver yeah
and i think that that sort of that
epiphany came to him like
i
really like last year i'll tell you last
year was like one of the most fun years
he's had in coaching
and so i think the idea of running that
back was actually really appealing to
him and i think he knows with the group
that he's had there's a good chance
there's gonna be more bites at the apple
down the road do you think jerry jones i
know sean payton denied it do you think
jerry jones reached out to sean payton's
people
i mean i don't think he has to reach out
to his people
those two
all right i was trying to be fair to the
situation
but
you know what i'm saying like i don't
think jerry needs to do you thinking
do you think jerry jones called up sean
pig
i think they've talked probably yeah
like i like and i i you know they're
very close like that's not like a phony
relationship that's not like a a surface
relationship that a guy who used to
coach there has with an owner like
that's a genuine relationship so
you know i'm sure at one point or
another even if it was just say hey
congratulations on a great run in new
orleans they talked
um and i don't think sean payton knows
and i don't know if like you kind of got
this from your talk with him damn but
i don't think sean payton knows what
he's going to do like i don't think he
knows what it's going to be like over
the next year and so
like could he wind up in dallas in 2023
absolutely you know like his his kid one
of his kids is in college there
um you know obviously he spent a good
period of his life there
both his kids went to high school there
so like the idea of going back to dallas
coaching for jerry having that team like
i think that appeals to him and maybe he
does that in 2023 i also wouldn't rule
out and and i'd i'd love to hear your
opinion because you talked to him
yesterday
like i don't think it's impossible he's
bill cower you know what i mean like
where you think he's going back and
everybody says it'll be a year or two
and then he just decides that he likes
the life that television affords him
where he's working 35 days a year and
making millions and
not having to worry about you know how
he's going to cover the other team's
tight end um every week well i did bring
that up to him i said you know you if
you're going to do this you have to
commit to it it's not something you can
master in one year and i even brought up
what jim nance said to me earlier this
week he and tony romo felt like that
they had their best game that chief's
bills game that's five years of working
together and i said to sean he goes well
if you know me i don't do anything half
you know i i go all in on it and i said
you have to do that if you want to be
great at it and it seemed like he was
willing to at least explore that let me
go back to the situation with denver
with nathaniel hacken explain
how they could pull off a deal that
would get them devonte adams and aaron
rodgers
so they're in good shape cap they've
been preparing for this like they've
been preparing to take their swing at a
quarterback it goes back i mean they
really like justin fields
and you know like they were
of a mind maybe to take him and they
decided all right like let's wait let's
do like the prudent thing with the
conservative thing they got patrick
certain who's a really good piece and
let's continue to build assets they
trade von miller during the year like
cap wise they're in good shape they've
got a lot of guys who are on rookie
contracts
and they've set it up
so aaron rodgers can walk in there and
bring people with him
and so um but what if i give up because
you're gonna have to trade him
right you have to trade for him what for
for devonte no what do you you gotta
trade for uh roger rogers three
first-round picks
do you think that would get it done i
know that they don't i was told they
don't green bay doesn't want players
they want to get picks picks right yeah
so like i don't like i think it's gonna
take i think it's gonna take pics
because now you're talking about okay
like green bay's got a little bit of a
cap issue and the way you solve that is
by getting younger and that's you know
where your cheap labor comes from is the
draft
and um and yeah i mean i think if the
packers if this if that's the way it
goes if two weeks from now
rogers and the packers come to the same
sort of decision that like matthew
stafford and the lions came to last year
and they decided we're going to part
ways i think denver's at the top of the
list i think denver appeals to aaron
rodgers
and i know the broncos believe this dan
and i think i brought this up to you
before
they're not that different now than they
were in 2012 when they went and got
peyton manning right like you look at
the way the team's set up
young skill position talent like they
had with decker and thomas and thomas um
in 2012. now they've got judy they've
got hamler they've got sutton they've
got patrick they've got phant they've
got javonte williams and then on defense
back then they had the young pass rusher
the young corner von miller chris harris
what do they have now bradley chubb
patrick certain so
like you've got the structure of like a
young team a lot of those guys on rookie
contracts which gives you [ __ ] cap
flexibility and you can say to aaron
everybody on this team is getting better
right now so you're going to be joining
a team that's ascending and oh by the
way because those guys are on rookie
contracts we can maybe do a few things
to make the team even better bring some
guys you're comfortable with in here so
yeah i mean and then items they just
they could yeah can the packers
franchise him but they can but it's
tricky
the packers would need like adams would
almost need to play ball with them
because they can't trade him unless he
signs his tender
and if he wanted to
he could just say i'm not signing it
they can't trade him
so
he could actually because they're 45
million over the cap the
the franchise tag for receivers is about
18 million
so at the very least you've got to carry
him onto your roster into the new league
gear to trade him which means you'd have
to create that 18 million dollars of cap
space when you're already 45 million
over
so to some degree
devante adams would have to play ball
with the packers and why would he do
that like if he knows they're trading
aaron rodgers if that's what happens
like why would he say yeah i'll go and
make sure that you get a first round
pick from somebody else and make sure
that i'm not going to make it to the
open no he's going to want to go to the
open market so i think that because of
the cap logistics
devonte is in
in a in a spot where he could leverage
his way to free agency and then if he
wanted to just go sign with whatever
team rogers winds up with
great to talk to you thanks again for
joining us on short notice and uh enjoy
the weekend
all right thanks dan thanks buddy that's
albert breer senior nfl reporter lead
content strategist for the monday
morning quarterback